hey you guys so we have another
announcement then hopefully is kind of a
cool announcement Tom yeah well I'm kind
of mad because you know girls are always
say they're cold
it's got to be 95 degrees it is not
she's wearing Oh 95 degrees in here okay
whatever it's probably like seven I
wouldn't be wearing a sweater if I was
outside I think it's hot as hell anyway
haha oh man I got that man's metabolism
you know it's running hard and I'm
constantly late but he's hotter than a
woman you okay you guys notice my office
I'm the one that sits in here all day
and work he comes in and turns my air
conditioner on okay look after I told
him not there because because we're on
our own and we can do whatever the hell
we want now we decided we're going to
expand to show out into into another
direction that Jenny and I love we love
movie reviews yeah especially if they're
funny but not necessarily not realize
Brennan ten old who else does a good
movie review well I really like Hugo and
Jake use a Bible reloaded they just do
like cheesy Christian movies but they're
hilarya they're like in depth ones I
like those too well so we wanted to
review some movies that were like
important to us yeah on personal level
mostly they're mostly going to be horror
movies sci-fi movies that type the bank
yeah some of them will be new but a lot
of them will be kind of the older horror
movies from the 80s and yeah one of the
things that I noticed is that a lot of
guys hit a roof you in movies are young
so let's say for instance they're
talking about the movie predator
predator one they weren't they didn't
see that movie when it came out they
weren't even born
then a lot of yeah I mean so they don't
understand the context and they'll ask I
don't know what the audience's reaction
to this would have been well I know I
was there all right I know what it's
like to be a little kid and your dad
takes you to see alien one and the chest
bursts or pops out and I know what how
the audience reacted to that I was there
you know so we're going to take it down
that pat yeah we definitely wanted to
pick movies that were you know kind of
significant to us in some way or you
know ones we just liked a lot from what
we were
going up or like I said even newer ones
that I really kind of should give them a
few awful lists of what we're going yeah
we have like oh and I should say too
that are in minutes our list channel
that's going to continue that's not good
enough we're going to do that as well
but this is just going to be another
little extra thing we're proud we're not
going to make like a separate channel
for it now we'll keep it on this these
will just be on the regular 13 o'clock
channel just periodically whenever we do
them yeah we might put them in a
different playlist yeah I'll just make
me separate Playland Rob I'm not going
to make a separate just as an example it
kind of moves through samba got to get
to Omega man yeah gotta get to predator
got to get to the evil the haunting the
thing Mulla and drive you want on yeah I
got to do a little Lynch oh they look
like people the invitation the tenant
Suspiria one called inframan we have to
talk about I thought that was such a
great moment hunger we're going to talk
about Dead Ringers
alien and aliens I definitely got a show
on skate from New York
he loves escape from New York you guys
don't even know dune conan the last man
on earth
burnt offerings and maybe some korean
flicks yeah they were plans of other
ones like it I mean you know I I have a
blog which I mentioned on the show
sometimes got it's a tell fire and I
review movies on their run so I'll
probably cover in some of those movies
so many older ones in the new ones that
I did on there and you think I probably
some other ones as well yeah probably
the ones that Jenny really is the one
she really knows about you and all that
her she can leave with those yeah and do
research my reviews will probably be
more like just a review just pure
testosterone driven you know about how
do you think I'm gonna go buy a script
because think about it I mean these
movies have already pretty much been
reviewed but by me buggy nationals
you know guys that have a whole channels
on this you know who the director is who
is who the sound engineer was who the
key grip was you know they know that
kind of stuff it wasn't I'm like I'm
going to do my life like that mine will
be more amusing I think even though I
like I love those kind of reviews yeah
it's just not gonna be scholarly it's
gonna be pure emotional that is not
surprising yeah that's just that's how
you do that that's how I roll yeah what
will also take
request to if you guys can come up with
some good movies that you want reviewed
you know if we've seen it move it oh
yeah that's good idea we'll do that one
you know yeah cuz it's our first to kind
of think of every single movie we want
to do I mean you know we're not doing
walk sometimes and we exercise in the
pop-up and I had an old movie yeah it
was a good one yeah it's what yeah
because we kind of made two separate
lists because even though we agreed on
some we wanted to because we definitely
want to do like the saying and stuff
like that because that's one of my
favorite movies and when his favorite
movies yeah but um I think I see a lot
more horror movies than you do or I've
seen a lot more horror movies in you
especially recently yeah and I've seen a
lot more recent ones too because a lot
of amido you haven't seen i like clown
we saw clown yeah i actually kind of
looked everything it was dumb but it was
like really interesting i reminded me of
the old movies that we kind of grew up
with well is a very linear see now
that's why i wanted to do some newer
movies too because I've recently started
watch like for my blog mostly I started
going on Netflix and I said man I'm
going to like check out some newer
horror movies because because I've been
hearing a lot of good things about a lot
of newer horror films because a lot of
them are throwbacks right to the 80s and
a lot of them are set in the 70s and 80s
which i think is kind of read which I
guess I guess like younger filmmakers do
that cause it oh well no one has cell
phone so that makes it a lot of scarier
when you can't just go hey help me you
know what I mean plus the directors of
the that era back then were they were
really good
they were even the cheap movies well
some of them something like what was his
name the guy did shits on its own took
my time we just talked about is it got
it did the thing John Carpenter
those weren't really high budget movies
but they were really well crafted yeah
they were works of art you know well and
we were talking about how if you do
really good practical effects that movie
will never date yeah
CGI will yeah because I mean if you see
movies that were made in the 90s with
the CFI of the 90s they look horrible
right but you can watch a movie from the
80s that was done with really good
practical effects like an American
Werewolf in London for example or
predator and that look still looks
fantastic even though it was the
[ __ ] predator was what 30 years ago
yeah and 20-something
almost 30 years in yeah I was a kid was
that 1987 days Evan yeah I remember it
was the high school I was in high school
yeah I was in junior I was going high
cool that was a senior I think but
anyway that we'll talk about that later
but yeah I mean you can watch printer
today next gen that that holds its own I
mean well that a patoot it still says
ask me oh that's badass like oh that
creature design yeah it actually the
original looked better than the ones out
of aliens yeah or with no predators yeah
you know I thought they did actually
yeah it looks better anyway
okay so I hope you guys are excited
about that and if any of y'all have any
um we said y'all
well I'm something there something
intestines you said y'all bless your
heart I got it I'm a southern why don't
everybody I do it to something thinking
about well he is mostly when you talk to
your dad on the phone working man if he
already gets mad done to Center exa even
though you're even though you were born
and come out of ammunition you lived in
Mississippi for long yeah anyway so so
if you guys have any ideas for movies
warrants to old ones or new ones doesn't
really matter um
Tom's kind of likes he likes more action
movies you like monster movies do I kind
of like more artsy fartsy movies ghost
stories that kind of stuff you know so
we'll kind of cover a lot yeah and I
think you leave me asleep yeah he
doesn't like that so those are the ones
I better talk about I like surrealism
and like you know creep like subtle
ghost story no I went on you gun yeah
yeah he's you know he's like the typical
kind of yeah so but you fit big dudes
and single one so homoerotic who knows
what is right so if you have any ideas
for movies you want to do in the future
like I said I don't think we're going to
kind of adhere to any regular schedule
we're just going to put them up whenever
we want yeah and then the regular show
will just be up every I'll be regular
Tuesday and then the in minutes ones all
just put them up whatever I get my like
this even more so yeah we'll see how it
goes ok but uh so yeah I hope you guys
enjoy that and give us some ideas I am